bonjour claude est heureuse de me
retrouver un jour dans cette matinale
verte et français crise migratoire aux
portes de l'europe comment est-ce qu'on
en est arrivé là sans depuis quelques
mois il ya une sorte de pont aérien
entre le proche-orient et minsk et ce
point rien naturellement qui a permis à
un certain nombre de migrants d'arriver
à minsk ne s'est pas organisé
spontanément ça veut dire que des
réseaux mafieux et les officines au
proche orient ont fabriqué un produit un
forfait qui étaient là les simples
jusqu'à disque avec une chambre d'hôtel
avec des adresses pour poursuivre le
chemin et puis évidemment catalyseur
essentiel un visa biélorusse donc il ya
une collusion forcément entre ces
réseaux et les gens qui ont délivrer les
visas le biélorusse c'est à dire le
gouvernement biélorusse pour amener tous
ces migrants qui ne veulent pas rester à
minsk qui ont eu ce qu'ils cherchent en
fait à entrer dans l'union européenne
dans tel ou tel pays de l'union
européenne mais là où le calcul de ceux
qui ont imaginé ce dispositif est en
train d'échouer c'est que il se trouve
que la pologne et la lituanie qui sont
au contact de la biélorussie ont
évidemment protéger leurs frontières en
mettant des garde frontières des
policiers les militaires des barbelés
et que aujourd'hui la lituanie avec
l'aide des agences européenne la pologne
ne veut pas entendre parler des agences
européennes donc elle utilise ses moyens
propres
contiennent ces réfugiés dans la zone
frontalière mais du côté pile russe
alors évidemment là on a une catastrophe
humanitaire qui est en train de ce2 ce2
se produire parce qu'ils aient des
femmes et des enfants il fait très froid
il ya des gens qui sont malades il n'y a
pas de possibilité d'aller soigner les
médecins sans frontières médecins du
monde ne sont pas admis en biélorussie
bien entendu et les journalistes en plus
et par conséquent et par conséquent on
est là devant une crise humanitaire
importante alors il faut on parlera sans
doute tout à l'heure des solutions
éventuelles alors on parle beaucoup de
biélorussie de pologne mais quelles sont
les forces en présence sur place les
sanctions européennes est ce qu'elles
peuvent apaiser la situation mais
d'abord il ya ceux qui ont contribué à
alimenter ce flux de réfugiés on a dit
que dans les réfugiés y avait pas mal de
de kurdes par conséquent j'imagine que
je veux le gouvernement erdogan s'est
employé à se débarrasser d'un certain
nombre de kurdes dans ce flux de
réfugiés
peut-être y at-il d'ailleurs des
terroristes en puissance qui seraient
partis de syrie ou qui serait partie en
irak donc il faudra un jour filtrer ces
migrants avant de les accepter ou que ce
soit et puis effectivement
les autres pays de l'union européenne
ont fait bloc en soutenant la pologne et
la lituanie en s'étonnant que la pologne
n'accepte pas l'intervention les agences
européennes mais ça c'est évidemment la
posture particulière de la pologne
vis-à-vis du processus européen et puis
on voit bien que madame merkel
monsieur macron parle aussi au président
poutine et qu'il ya d'ailleurs une sorte
de courant pour faire baisser la
pression et pour envoyer le message à
leucate chaque go qu'il faut résoudre ce
problème je crois d'ailleurs que le fait
que le conseil de sécurité des nations
unies on ait disputé la semaine dernière
jeudi
condamné
lamaneurs la manoeuvre biélorusse le
fait que poutine est démentie
loukachenko lorsque celui ci a dit je
vais couper le gaz à l'europe poutine a
dit il en est pas question parce qu'il
ya des contrats et et nous on respecte
nos contrats par conséquent on voit bien
qu'il ya là les grandes puissances qui
se met en mouvement pour essayer de
résoudre le conflit maintenant il faut
trouver les moyens pratiques les moyens
pratiques c'est d'abord cesser les flux
d'approvisionnement les faire cesser des
flux d'arrivées pardon et c'est en train
de se faire parce que pour une fois la
diplomatie européenne a fonctionné en
allant dans les différentes capitales
d'où partait les migrants pour expliquer
que ça n'était pas possible et que
naturellement des sanctions seraient
prises contre eux turkish airlines
contre les rives aérienne qui
transportait les migrants contre les
mafieux qui vendait les forfaits et que
finalement on voit que les différents
gouvernements ont compris le message et
ont donné des ordres pour que les
départs de migrants à destination de
minsk cesse maintenant reste à résorber
les neuf mille migrants qui sont coincés
dans cette nasse et effectivement ça
n'est pas très commode après tout
naïvement pourrait imaginer que ceux qui
les ont amenés là devrait organiser leur
retour est d'ailleurs le payer puisqu'il
y avait pas de ticket de retour
simplement apparemment ça n'est pas leur
état d'esprit puisqu'on parle à minsk
maintenant de canaliser les migrants
vers l'allemagne mais évidemment il n'y
a aucune raison que l'allemagne accepte
ces migrants qui ont été assemblées à
minsk de façon artificielle un
commentaire la russie a dit que
finalement l'europe était confrontée à
ses propres responsabilités elle a
critiqué un manque d'humanité justement
par rapport à au sort de ces migrants
on peut toujours dire que l'europe
manque d'humanité effectivement elle
pourrait axer accepter les migrants du
monde entier pour faire preuve
d'humanité mais on sait bien que ce
n'est pas possible et que parent
conseiller que là il manoeuvre en effet
qui a été de manoeuvre de
déstabilisation
de pays de l'union européenne et
peut-être de l'union européenne elle
même par conséquent elle ne peut que
contrer cette manoeuvre c'est ce qu'elle
fait on voit bien que la pologne
d'ailleurs joue un jeu un peu un peu à
peu compliqué mais ce que la pologne se
présente comme étant les avant-postes de
la frontière européenne responsable de
la gare de cette frontière et qu'elle
demande le soutien de l'otan dans le
fond elle est encore plus soucieuses
d'avoir le soutien de l'otan veulent
avoir le soutien de l'union européenne
merci beaucoup glochos bleus de blanche
maison pour votre éclairage en édito à
revoir bien évidemment sur les réseaux
sociaux on vous retrouve mardi prochain
dramatique